well i think today's figures show
actually that our economy is clearly
getting back on track in particular if
you look at the numbers
for march but crucially they show that
our plan for jobs
is working and i think that's the
important thing that i take away from
today's figures
look of course many households and
families are still facing tough times
and that's why
our support is continuing restrictions
will start to ease further on
monday be able to come inside places
like this for a drink and further on
june the 21st but you'll know
the hospitality industry particularly
wants more certainty if restrictions
don't entirely go
will some economic support remain well
we provide a considerable support
to the hospitality industry through this
crisis and that support
continues and it continues well beyond
the end of the road map and the business
we're in today is a great example
of that where they've been able to
furlough staff but are now
brilliantly brought them back to work
they're also taking on new
employees a kickstarter which is
fantastic and they've benefited
from discretionary cash grants and other
hospitality benefit
businesses have benefited from the vat
cut or indeed business rates holidays
so you know i know it's a tough time for
the hospitality industry but the crucial
thing is we're making progress on the
road map next week will be a big week
and i want to bring as many of those
furloughed workers back to work
and that's what we're seeing in today's
figures our plan for jobs is working
if social distancing in any form or any
restrictions remain and 100 capacity
can't be reached that's the difference
between
being viable and not so will you
leave some support if you don't remove
all the restrictions you've placed on
business
well i think i'd say two things the
prime minister's said that we're in
good shape to continue making progress
on the road map so i think that should
fill
uh people with some confidence and
optimism about the future
but also our support continues beyond
the end of the roadmap whether it's
business rates
reductions or vat cuts or furlough
all those things continue well beyond
the end of the roadmap so that support
is in place
last summer you stimulated spending eat
out to help out you planning anything
similar are you just going to trust
consumers
to get out there and spend the money
though so so i think as a result of the
actions that we've taken over the past
year we've managed to protect a lot of
household incomes and you see that in
the recent economic figures
and i think that bodes well for the rest
of the year
our plan is working consumers have built
up savings obviously that's not
evenly distributed and what we now know
which we didn't know a year ago that
actually as things open up
people do want to get out and go back to
doing the things that they used to do
and i think we will see that in the
coming weeks and months as we are
already seeing it
in today's figures which show that our
plan is working can they trust though
that you're not
going to knock down the economy again
can can they trust to spend those
savings
the risk that you might close things
down again well i think people can see
with the success of the vaccine roll out
and with as the prime minister explained
earlier this week as well you know we
are meeting all the tests for progress
on
the roadmap and people are doing a
fantastic job
of following all the rules and that's
enabled us to
bit by bit reopen our economy reduce the
restrictions people go back to doing the
things that they love doing i think
that's
enormously positive and that's why we're
seeing whether it's consumer confidence
which is returned
to pre-crisis levels business confidence
you know there's an enormous amount of
optimism about the future
and you know i take a lot of heart from
that and it makes me think that the plan
we put in place a year ago
is working should people go back to the
office and if so when
i said obviously you know we'll get to
later stages of the road map
later that is a decision for employees
and employers
and you know i would imagine as many
people are having those conversations
about some degree of flexibility and
work arrangements that's absolutely
right that those conversations should
happen around four million people at
least still on furlough
how many of them do you think will be
unemployed come the end of the year
well what we do know now is that
furlough has worked in protecting
millions of people's jobs over the past
year
and if you look at the unemployment rate
for example here in the uk
it is lower than most of our major
competitors whether that's america
canada france spain
italy and that's important to me because
protecting people's jobs is my number
one priority
you know and i believe that as we reopen
the economy we can get as
many of those people back to work as
possible um how many is that how many is
what
well as the economy reopens we'll see
but i've always been clear not every
single job
is going to be one that we can save but
that's why it's important that we
provide new opportunities for people
whether it's through our
apprenticeship bonuses the kickstart
scheme the prime minister's lifetime
skills guarantee
all of those provide fresh opportunity
and hope for people
and that's what we will deliver on this
year how are you going to pay for social
care
i think the government remains committed
to supporting the social care system and
as we set out in our manifesto we
already are an
extra billion pounds a year has already
been invested
into the social care system